HTML markup is made up of things called tags.
Tags look something like this.
The way a tag is structured is,
you've got a less than symbol,
the tag name, a greater than symbol,
the tag contents--which can actually be other tags--
or it could just be text--another less than symbol,
a slash, the name, and a greater than symbol.
There's two ways I might refer to this.
We would call this the opening tag;
this one, the one with the slash in front of the name,
we'd call this the closing tag.
The names are always the same,
and the only difference is the closing tag
has a slash in front of the name.
So you've always got name, contents, name.
Opening tag, contents, closing tag.
Now--I'll also refer to this whole thing as an element.
And--you know--this isn't something I'm really going to quiz you on,
I just want you to--you know--understand that
when I'm talking about HTML, I may refer to a tag,
or I may refer to the whole thing as the elements,
or sometimes I kind of switch the words a little bit,
but, that's what I'm referring to--
I'm just referring to this structure here.
Let's learn about our first tag.